former Democrat presidential candidate
and a Fox News contributor Tulsi
um there's been a noticeable shift in
the media's focus to really not run away
from the economy but to try to spin this
economy as something much different than
it actually is in the real life of most
Americans
alert it sounds like from some of the
conversations you've been having uh with
people there in Minneapolis they get
what all of these Spin Doctors don't
they they actually see what's happening
which is quote unquote biodynamics are
failing the American people but what
people in Washington are not focusing on
enough is what actually is Dynamics
binomics essentially is fascism a kind
of national socialism where we have
government bureaucrats and and and
politicians partnering in colluding with
these massive corporations and the ultra
Rich to make these business deals uh
picking winners and losers that serve
their own self-interest in the interests
of the power elite at the cost of the
well-being of the American people not
only today but in the increasing debt
that they are incurring incurring that
will affect us for generations to come
and foremost the perfect example of this
Laura you and I've talked about this
before is the military industrial
complex they have essentially a blank
check a unaccounted amount of spend
ending of taxpayer dollars and if you or
I or anyone else's hey uh is all that
you're spending actually strengthening
our national security is it serving the
best interests of the American people
and maybe perhaps we should know where
every dollar is being spent if we say
that we are at risk of being called
unpatriotic I've been called that before
for asking these very questions and so
people aren't even allowed to challenge
or question where this spending is going
and how it's benefiting uh the American
people what to speak of our economy and
and everyday Americans being able to
frankly survive and live comfortably
what to speak of prosper in the United
States of America
now Biden wants us all I think Tulsi to
kind of clap like seals since year over
year inflation isn't as high as it was
last year but since he's taken office
consumer prices have gone up nearly 16
percent we obviously know what's
happened with energy costs
um now this is something that is really
hitting the middle class the lower
middle class really really hard the
elites are kind of gliding above it as
they usually do
and that's exactly what we're seeing as
as President Biden and his
administration and the elites are
celebrating quote unquote biodynamics uh
the American people know better because
uh those successes that are being touted
are actually the opposite is being felt
uh and and again this is where we have
to hold the Biden Administration the
Democrat Elite accountable this is not
about well we just have to message
things better that's always their answer
rather than actually looking at what the
problem is because doing that would
require them to look in the mirror
Tulsi great to see you thanks so much
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else